Les Italiens se lancent dans une aventure vers la
destination la plus exquise du monde
un lieu d'histoire préservée d'
une beauté incomparable et d'une tranquillité sans précédent
J'ai vu midi se fondre
dans le vert jusqu'à l'architecture italienne accrochez-vous
[Musique
] c'était le café de Pologne
cela se produit lorsque vous essayez de voler plus
pays
ouais nous aurions probablement pu utiliser pour
échauffer la mission
Blitzer 4.80 moi ici
j'arrive
[Applaudissements]
désolé d'avoir crié
pas le David oh non non le David
avez-vous déjà voulu sortir et comparer ou
devrions-nous peut-être penser  à propos d'y aller ouais
cette saison de vacances
arrête ton aventure en Italie
dieu j'aime l'Italie
[Musique]
toi